[Music]
new research out this morning claims to
show a link between an increased risk of
car crashes and legal marijuana use the
highway loss data Institute looked at
auto collision claims in Washington
Oregon and Colorado those are the states
where recreational use is legal
it says claims are up about three
percent since marijuana sales began Mary
Peterson shows us the safety concerns
and the skepticism about this study he's
at a pot dispensary in Denver all right
very good morning good morning well
three years ago Colorado legalized
marijuana for recreational use and this
study now seems to show a link between
marijuana use and an increase in traffic
accidents for those who supported
legalizing marijuana I have to tell you
this study is not going to be very good
news Colorado led the nation with the
first sales of legal recreational
marijuana in 2014 but the drugs impact
on roadway crashes has not been well
documented today the highway loss data
Institute reported an increase in
insurance claims filed for collisions in
Colorado Washington and Oregon three
states where recreational marijuana is
legal Matt Moore oversaw the study
Colorado just relative to the states
around it we're seeing an increase of
almost fourteen percent but those
numbers do not match with the Colorado
State Patrol has tracked sergeant Rob
Madden says the agency has actually seen
a decrease in the number of driving
impaired accidents since pot sales
became legal two years of data is not
enough to allow us to draw conclusions
to come up with an explanation of
what is safe what is not safe Sankar
Brian Vicente represents pot shops and
played a major role in Colorado's
legalization typically you can drink one
beer and drive but if you have three
you're over the limit states are taking
a hard look to try to figure out what is
that free beer limit for marijuana
there have been tragedies from mixing
marijuana and driving last year high
school student Chad Britton was killed
by a teen driver high on pot and while
pot may be legal impaired driving is not
even though it's that much harder to
detect what we are looking for is is the
impairment that we see while speaking to
the drivers the state of Colorado in the
marijuana industry together have started
a campaign they call buzzkill this is
one of the brochures a tagline says a
DUI will ruin your high the State Patrol
says of all the people they stop for
driver impairment about 17% are from
marijuana use but they say connecting
marijuana used to an increase in traffic
accidents is a very much ongoing and
they say very much unresolved debate
nora alright very thank you